we could have walked one flavor of
stairs sure where are the stairs exactly
I didn't see any either Ryan Hoffman is
back in Brussels home turf that was nice
so this is it yeah true senator teofisto
funkier poly bug Lucy's not know huh
everyone here has been waiting for
Germany's most powerful trade unionist
he represents 6 million members I
thought you were on hidden zay Island
you've set the wrong priorities a public
discussion begins the head of Germany's
trade union confederation the d gb is a
star guest some greet him with presents
I have something for you too I was in
Madrid yesterday and tomorrow I fly to
the United States and when I packed
everything I forgot that and left it at
home but i'll send it to you with the
mail thanks if you want to get things
done you need friends especially in
brussels the money for salah was it
there are 28 member countries in the
european union the variety is tremendous
with different cultures and different
political orientations each embedded in
the structures of nation states I
emitted India wonderful not too large to
arrive at joint solutions you need a bit
of patience a fast sprint won't help you
need a bit of endurance kind it's a
marathon blin suitable one on the scene
all store does mahajan on dessert yes
Griner Hoffman has been working for
years on today's topic when will the
European Union institute a common
unemployment insurance with jobless
people in Spain and Greece receiving
money from Brussels instead from Madrid
and Athens would that be the path out of
the crisis in Europe the German trade
unionist says things can't continue as
they are the elite in quarter units in
the last few years we've seen a
so-called crisis therapy that hasn't led
Europe out of the crisis at all but is
pushed individual member states to the
edge of the abyss good hot Smith I know
what schools cotton ball the average
unemployment rate in Europe is
twenty-five percent it's four to five
and a half million young people in
Europe have no jobs wyd schools in some
member states unemployment is up to
fifty percent bisou 50 pretend little
Ryan Hoffman calls for a
multibillion-euro pani you investment
program unlocked often listen to ask of
all time oh he would fuel growth and
drastically reduce unemployment stolen
bicycles visor you were zested puttin in
a tourney each tartan bodrum Adam after
the discussion Hoffman has another
urgent meeting and the camera is on hand
one year would it be possible to get a
haircut in the mall yes it's perfect
perfect
so now you're going to show how the
union's get a haircut I don't know if I
should let you film this you've been hit
before we is yes when I lived here I was
here regularly legally security for 15
years when Ryan Hoffman worked for the
European trade union confederation he
and his family lived in Brussels have
you ever had a different hairstyle i can
use bizarre not really i've been very
constant in my haircut except back in my
youth my hair was a bit longer back then
how long down to my shoulders come and
washed cut-and-dried he'll return to
Berlin and then it's off to Washington
he has friends there too